looks like Sam bankman free had given it
the largest financial fraud in modern
history but he's not in prison he didn't
trespass in the capital what's
interesting is that you are not allowed
to know the identity of the two people
who helped put up Sam bankman Freed's
Bond his lawyers even argued in court to
keep the names Mass to Shield them from
public criticism
now the media Outlets Took a ton of
money from Sam bankman freed like
semaphore haven't yet returned the money
that's stolen money they don't seem very
interested in how this has happened well
we are interested we just finished a
documentary in fact called scam bankman
fraud the story of FTX it's out on
Thursday on Fox Nation here's a preview
one of his strategies was to clutter his
sentences with technocratic jargon so no
one could really understand what he was
saying Alia did have a big position open
on FTX
um that position uh I think was you know
very over collateralized uh a year ago
there was a total Market collapse and
you know specifically large correlated
collapse in its assets you know over the
last month I I am no cryptocurrency
expert of no Finance actually but I
don't think you answered my question the
technocratic jargon is itself part of
the smoke screen too I have a general
rule of thumb if you cannot explain it
to a 14 year old that means either you
don't understand it yourself or you do
understand it and you're trying to
confuse the audience for a reason that
has to do with your own self-interested
game
Mr Ray Mr bankman freed has been able to
confuse interviewers by talking in
circles nothing that SBF have said has
said since the fraud was exposed has
been coherent even to this sophisticated
Observer of financial markets and I
think that's not just an accident It Is
by design it is another deflection
tactic
thank you
so the man you just saw in that clip is
one of the people who acted as a sherpa
for us as we tried to understand what
was happening with Sam banquet Phoenix
from fake ramaswamy a frequent guest in
the show executive chairman of strive
Asset Management he joins us in studio
tonight Vic thanks so much for coming on
um I loved your point and I think it's
one of the the truest guides to other
people's talking but tell me why Sam
bankman freed seems to be treated so
much more gently than your average
criminal defendant well it's because he
had the entire deflection tactic set up
and it wasn't just the jargon it was the
ESG smoke screen it was the good guy who
was engaged in effective altruism
funding Democratic candidates he knew
how to play the game to be able to
create the appearance that he cared
about something other than profit and
power when in fact he cared only about
more profit and power for himself but
the thing that was most striking to me
about the story Decker is not how this
is some sort of deviant who's so
different than how the rest of Wall
Street operates but how some familiar
his story really is it is the same story
as we saw back in 2008 I think there are
a lot of similarities it's going to make
a lot of people mad to hear this there's
a lot of similarities to what those ESG
promoting financial institutions do
today because what did SBF do he took
client funds without their permission
and used it to advance his agenda
without telling him guess what the
largest financial institutions in the
world are doing today they're using
somebody else's money without their
permission to advance their own agendas
and so what I find Most Fascinating
about the story isn't this this one guy
with curly hair was 30 years old that
was worth a lot of money and now isn't
that's just good detail I think it's an
interesting moment for everyone to look
in the mirror who's in Wall Street and
everywhere else and ask themselves how
dissimilar his story really is to what
even mainstream actors in financial
markets it's a wise point I mean these
are people who are motivated by a lot of
things but one of them is a desire to
accumulate as much money as possible we
know that it's fine but we have
Regulators we're supposed to keep that
within the bounds like Gary Gensler
where are they okay they're busy focused
on advancing those same agendas right
why are they propagating ESG disclosure
rules when in fact they should be
focused on preventing people from losing
money right you would think this was an
objective and the irony is they're going
to use this as a catalyst to say well
now we need to have greater purview over
regulating cryptocurrencies or whatever
when in fact this is just a managerial
class that's advancing a political
agenda and the more you advance a
political agenda the less you're doing
the job that you're actually supposed to
do and you know well Tucker that is the
story of the administrative State the
SEC included as we know it so just
really quick if it is true that what Sam
bankman free did is not so different
from what a lot of people are doing
right now are you concerned about the
stability of our financial system
so look I've had concerns dating back to
2008. the thing that we didn't let
happen in this country Tucker was when
those Banks actually heard back then we
should have let them fall and actually
teach this system its lesson instead the
lesson we taught was the worse you act
the more likely you are to get bailed
out by the system SPF was a young guy
that's the system he grew up what else
do you expect by the next generation of
fraudsters do the same thing a decade
and a half later and clearly his parents
encouraged this I mean you could just
imagine this kid pulling the same scam
at 13. you know yeah isn't he cute he's
so smart Okay
um great to see you thank you good for
your very crisp analysis subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube channel to catch
our nightly opens stories that are
changing the world and changing your
life from Tucker Carlson tonight